all right we are armed ready to fire in
three two one this Clank matches into a
window to simulate flying debris sir
forest this is incredible
wind engineers at the University of
Florida have been conducting experiments
like these two the past eight years the
data that's produced show how building
materials hold up in the most violent
weather all right and lead to the
development of building codes and new
standards for weather proofing let's
create a hurricane in a laboratory
we can't wait for next event develop -
this allows us to replicate hurricanes
that are expected to happen every year
so we're talking about millions or
billions of dollars in savings if by the
research that you're doing a billion
billions of dollars of course anywhere
from three to five billion dollars a
year are caused by hurricanes this has
flowed 200 mile-per-hour winds across a
typical shingled roof the concrete
shatters into tiny pieces the wind
speeds up to a little over 200 miles per
hour but this machine is capable of
replicating over 230 mile-per-hour winds
which is really you know the worst that
nature spiria can bring we're going to
raise the load until we see a kind of
trophic layer
here's what happens when intense wind
pressure is applied to a garage door oh
my goodness this particular system can't
produce the types of loads you'd see on
an extreme category five storm the top
of a skyscraper or an ef-4 tornado in a
low-rise building if you have my debris
we're always going to have to live with
extreme weather but what we can do is
engineer the places that we live and
work to withstand the storms of today or
100 years from now
you